crucial moments in this game but I just
want to highlight one that Robert
actually mentioned but kokesh simply
didn't have enough time to calculate and
it was this critical moment white is
trying to play King of the Hill my
favorite variant by the way trying to
get the king into the center of the
board but this did allow black one
moment to save the game Knight takes
porn getting rid of those strong white
pawns would potentially have turned
things around somewhat what black does
get two pawns for the night this is a
check and maybe a third Pawn would drop
off on the edge of the board later
suddenly you've got rid of the strongest
part of White's position and great
chances to save the game instead he let
the pawn survive he simply moved his
Rook to the wrong side of the board and
we if we fast forward to the end
now we saw the final stages of this game
the white Rook centralized and uh once
the pawn started stepping forward in the
center there was no way to save the game
Rook d8 eliminating the blockader and
white was about to make a new Queen
today's learning point is about how to
how to play for a win at all costs good
cash in the opening surprised his
opponents Eric icy with some really
creative and and some really clever play
in this position he shocked us all here
all the commentators by playing H4 what
is this doing you might ask he's simply
going to push his Pawn forward and make
it less attractive for the black king to
Castle on the king side his next move
another shock King to F1 putting the
King on a slightly odd square but uh
committing to lifting his Rook up the
board where as we saw in the game it did
prove to be a very strong piece it was a
crazy game of course many many twists
and turns later kokesh sacrificed his
Queen but uh Eric icy at the right
moment was able to lock things down by
giving his own Queen back I definitely
recommend playing through all of this
game it's well worth a study yeah it
looks like Magnus because of the clock
was reluctant to start a race which
would have been in his favor instead he
waited for one move too long he tried to
finesse it and uh the moment passed and
the wind Slipped Away it started in this
position we said the black king was
getting active he was getting ready to
jump towards those white pawns if for
example we start by capturing a Pawn on
the side of the board the black king
could start advancing but Magnus if he'd
had two minutes on his clock he would
have had the time to work out that he is
winning he could move his King out of
the way yes the black king can come in
but it's simply too slow the white Pawn
can step forward now the king can take
this Pawn but at the right moment you
will go and kick this Knight away with
the white king and uh you'll have a safe
run through to promotion Magnus missed
this job this opportunity if we go back
and uh whoops not to this position we
did eventually see King and Knight
versus King it was a draw for one move
it was very very temporary but Magnus
did miss the moments he replied
instantly and uh he did regret it as we
saw on the camera a moment ago it was
here that uh Hikaru played a bit of a
careless move he brought his Bishop in
this is uh tempting it's very
understandable very human you want to
block the defile this bishop is very
annoying to get rid of for black but
Magnus missed that just this one moment
he could uh slide his Queen back hitting
this white rook in the corner and
suddenly nowhere good to run for this
white Rook if you run across the board
preventing a move will show in a moment
then suddenly you just drop a pawn the
Blackfoot will happily take this Pawn
material advantage and a winning
position instead if you defend this
point if you keep it defended then
Bishop to C3 does pose a big problem for
this white Rook suddenly this white Rook
is tied down it doesn't have too many
squares to go to and this bishop will be
lost for example if it tries to come up
the board then you can overwhelm uh this
bishop due to a pin on the default
guaranteed to win material at least a
rook for Bishop and Magnus would have
guided this to Victory it was uh it was
really instructive how Hikaru just
hovered off all the pieces and kept a
measure of control throughout we
mentioned in this position he had a
choice he could have captured this white
knight and uh maybe imbalanced it
slightly kept the game alive kept the
Queen's kept the Rooks on the board but
he said no he'd calculated very
accurately that these doubled B pawns
were well compensated for uh by his
dynamism his peace activity we saw the
Rooks leave the board magnus's Knight
had to step out of the attack and this
queen move every move from here till the
end was very accurate from both sides we
saw an offer of a queen trade Hikaru
said no not for you I'm opening well
conquering this open file and after a
few moves again this really precise move
order that Tanya mentioned dropping the
Knight into E4 far more accurate than
any Queen trade than any Rook trade and
uh The Logical end of the game was this
one a little dance between the bishop
and queen the queen has nowhere to go
other than to take this Pawn if it wants
to defend B4 and that status quo
continues for the remaining moves a
repeat a repetition to end the game but
a federal
Magnus did play a really exemplary game
we should mention Hikari tried
everything he tried to throw a Magnus
off balance he tried to hustle on the
clock but to no avail and it was
actually here that Magnus had a winning
shot he didn't spot it it was difficult
we should mention it was Knight takes
Pawn just to open up a check against the
white king this check would have been
deadly if the Knight had been recaptured
a check the king moves in maybe the one
that Magnus hadn't spotted is that you
first have to push this Pawn forward to
break the white Bishop's connection with
this H6 Square next The Rook slides
across to win and uh if we fast forward
to the end game magnet here was in full
control he had these two running pawns
he should have been winning for black
but he found a really nice way to guide
it to safety and Hikaru never got a
chance to win on the board